[Müzik]
bir oyun oynayalım
şöyle bir Açılalım oyunumuz çok basit
sağ Elimizi kaldırıyoruz
şu şekilde
sol parmağımızı da kaldırıyoruz
sağ Elimizi yanımızdakinin sol parmağın
üstüne koyuyoruz
çok kafa karıştırmaya gerek yok
basit yani ne ben ne dediğimde
Ben sadece ve sadece dinle Yanımdakini
sol parmağını yakalamaya çalışıp telefon
aç
kolay şunu yapacaksın ya
ortalar birleşebilir isterseniz Yani
kenardakiler yaklaşabilirler
şöyle yaklaşabilirsiniz siz de
yaklaşabilirsiniz çok güzel
görünüyorsunuz bu arada
Yani hazır Bir deneyelim
Ben ne diyecektim
bir
iki
bu sessizliği çok seviyorum ya hemen
böyle hazırız zaten bir iki üç
yakalayanlar var gururunu duyuyorlar
Evet harika bir daha deneyelim şimdi ilk
oynadık çünkü hani İlkin hatası olabilir
bazı kurallarımız var böyle beklemek yok
bu yakalamış zaten
mızıkçılık yapmayın ikinci Kural
yanındakinin avucun için delmek yok
3 yakalanmış parmağı çekmek yok tamam mı
görüyorum çünkü bazı çekenler oldu Bir
de durmadan deneyenler var
yok hazır 1 1 1 1 1 1 2
2 2 2 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
[Alkış]
'da yakalanamıyoruz 9 8 7 6
5 4 3
[Alkış]
Harikasınız alkışlıyoruz sizi Süpersiniz
teşekkür ediyorum efendim
benle oyun oynadığınız için çok teşekkür
ediyorum
Evet bugünkü konumuzda Oyun iyi oldu
değil mi oynadığımız
nereyi görüyorsunuz nasıl bir yer Sizce
Burası neresi olabilir
oyun parkı güzel burası neresi olabilir
o tele benziyor Peki Burası neresi
okul Peki burası
başka bir okul ve Aslında ben bu işte
bir terslik olduğunu düşünüyorum Evet
yani sanki bir şeyi bir yerde yanlış
yapıyoruz ve Aslında çocukların bu kadar
çok bulundukları okullarda
neden oyunlara bu kadar çok önem
vermiyoruz ben buna çok üzülüyorum
bakıyoruz ki işte o AVM'lerde İşte o
otellerde hep böyle çocuklar için
alanlar var neden olduğunu az çok
biliyoruz ama asıl çocukların çok yoğun
bulunduğu bu okullarda neden çocuklar
için oyun alanları açmıyoruz sanki bu
bana yapmak istemiyoruz gibi geliyor o
yüzden bunu da Instagram'da buldum ben
çok ve dedim ki ya bunu görünce ya bu
bize çok uyuyor Eğer bir şey yapmak
istemiyorsak mutlaka bir bahanemiz var
ama yapmak istiyorsak da Mutlaka bir
yolunu buluyoruz ve onu yapmak için
çalışıyoruz dedim ya yapmak istemiyorsak
bahanemiz çok ve ben bütün bu bahaneleri
çok iyi biliyorum aranızda öğretmen
olanlar var mı
Evet bir sürü ebeveyn olanlar var mı
anneye de Baba oğluna harika ve ben
bütün bu bahane yani Çocuklarla oyun
oynamama bahanelerin hepsini Maalesef
çok yakından şahit oluyorum işte onlar
da şu an ekranda gördüklerimiz Hocam
işte Zaten yerimiz yok oynayacak
zamanımızda yok kargaşa oluyor çocuklar
terliyor Bunlar işte okul Burası Şimdi
burada oyun mu oynanır şimdi bizi test
çözmemiz lazım ders yapmamız lazım Sonra
Müdür geliyor hocam kusura bakmayın Ben
ders yok zannettim diyor hani alttan
alttan mesajlar veriyor O yüzden aslında
biraz daha fazla okullarda da oyun
oynayalım istiyorum az önce beni
tanıtırken söylediler Benim işim gücüm
oyun Ben sadece oyunlarla ilgili
çalışmalar yapıyorum oyunlarla ilgili
araştırmalar yapıyorum o kadar çok oyun
çalıştım ki
bu oyunların içerisinde bizim
çocuklarımızı bağımlı yapan şeylerin
neler olduğunu buldum
Sonra dedim ki ben bunları verileri
anlatmalıyım ebeveynlere O yüzden de
kitap yazdım bunu öğretmenlere
anlatmalıyım dedim O yüzden de kitap
yazdım Ve elimden geldiğince bu
oyunların içerisinde bu bağımlılık yapan
şeyleri
derslere okullara Entegre etmeye
çalışıyorum
ve maalesef de hala da yeterince oyun
oynamadığımızı görüyorum ama bir yandan
da dijital oyunlar oynamamız gerektiğini
de hissediyorum böyle Çocuklar da
oynuyorlar değil mi Ne oynuyor
çocuklarını
pubg oynuyor
roblox oynayanlar var Minecraft'ta
oynayanlar var bir sürü oyunlar
oynuyorlar ve tam bu noktada bir
araştırma yaptım dedim
ki ne oynamak istiyorlar acaba tam 5
binlik istediğiniz oyunu yazabilirsiniz
dedim istediğiniz oyunu ister dijital
oyunlar yazın ister fiziksel ister kutu
oyunu her şeyi yazabilirsiniz ne
demişlerdir
Saklambaç başka
evcilik roblox
çocuklar bize tokat gibi bir cevap
verdiler
çocukların en çok oynamak istedikleri
oyunlar
çocuklar bize Dediler ki biz Aslında
dijital bir oyun oynamak istemiyoruz biz
Aslında fiziksel oyunlar oynamak
istiyoruz ama yok
olmadığı için biz dijital oyunları
yönlendiriyoruz ve çocuklar Haklılar mı
çok Haklılar Neden Çünkü bu çocukların
bir sokakları yok değil mi kimler
sokakta büyüdü
kimler sokakta büyüdü için pişman Ulan
Merkez şu sokakta büyümeseydin diyen var
İyi ki sokakta büyümüşüz değil mi
sokakta sosyalleştik sokakta arkadaş
edindik sokakta öğrendik kazanmayı
kaybetmeyi yenmeyi yenilmeyi Lider
olmayı takım çalışması iletişimi sokakta
abilerimiz Ablalarımız Küçüklerimiz
fasulyelerimiz vardı hatırlayın onlara
Yardımcı olurduk onlara çok
dokundurmazdık sen de oyuna falan derdik
ve okuldan eve geldiğimizde çantayı
kapıyı bırakıp hemen sokağa çıkardık ne
zamana kadar güzel hayat ya
Bir de bedava
şimdi parasını veriyor O kadar çok
beceri elde ettiremiyorsun değil mi
Şimdiki Çocuklar ne yapıyor okuldan eve
geliyor çantayı bırakıyor hemen
bunun karşısına geçiyor ne yapacak ki
çocuk
çocuğu sokağa gönderebiliyor muyuz
gönderemiyoruz Neden oyun oynayacak yer
yok
oyun oynayacak arkadaş yok arkadaş varsa
da kim olduğunu bilmiyorum ama en
önemlisi de Sokaklar güvenli değil
güvenli olmadığı için de çocuğumu sokağa
gönderemiyorum haklı mıyım çok haklıyım
bizim elde ettiğimiz bütün o becerileri
bir düşünün
sokakta elde ettiğimiz o değerlerin
hepsini bir düşünün
ve şimdiki neslin bütün bu değerlerden
bütün bu becerilerden mahrum olduğunu
bir düşünün
Bu bir problem mi
bence çok büyük bir problem
ve bu probleme çözüm olsun diye Ben de
dedim ki bir şey yapalım ya bir şey
yapmamız lazım ve tam bu noktada oyun
dostu oku diye bir proje geliştirdik ben
istediğim ki bizim Artık yeni
sokaklarımız okullarımız olmalı Peki
okullar güvenli mi güvenli oyun
oynayacak yer var mı var arkadaş var mı
var Kim olduğunu biliyor muyum biliyorum
O zaman benim yeni sokağım okulum olsun
istiyorum ve bu sayede Aslında oyun
dostu okul projesiyle mümkün olduğunca
bizim yeni sokaklarımızı okullarımız
olmasına yönelik Aslında çalışmalar
yapmaya çalışıyorum ve burada neyi
amaçlıyorum Aslında zeminleri duvarları
mekanları bahçeleri koridorları okulun
ortak alanlarını sınıfların içerisine
her yeri oyun dostu hale getirmeye
hedefliyorum
Ve bu çok zor değil gerçekten
yapabileceğim şeyler Aslında
düşündüğünüz zaman yapması kolay şeyler
Hemen şimdi başlayabileceğimiz ve hemen
yapabileceğimiz şeylerden bahsediyorum
ve bunu denedik
aynı bölgede bulunan Aynı mahallede
bulunan iki Okulu aldık bir Okulu oyun
dostu Okulu yaptık diğer okulda olduğu
gibi bıraktık
başarı Evet hemen aklımıza başarı
geliyor başarı atmıştır Hocam bizim için
evet başarı
sınıfta
başka
mutlu olmuşlardır Bravo
Aslında baktığımız en önemli şey
mutluluktu acaba mutlulukları ne kadar
arttı diye baktık ve Evet o çocuklar
daha mutlu oldular ve mutlu olan çocuk
zaten başarılı oluyor
ve mutlu olan çocuk okula daha çok
gelmek istiyor okulda olmak istiyor
okulda oyun oynamak istiyor oyun oynamak
için okula geliyor Aslında
çocuk ve mümkün olduğunca
birkaç şey daha baktık Ama mesela çok
ilginçtir evdeki ekran süresi azaldı
evdeki ekran süresine nasıl etki etti
diye baktı çocuk Zaten yeterince okulda
oyun oynayınca artık yoruluyor orada
bütün o hazzını mutluluğunu alıyor Eve
gidince de gerek yok diyor çok yorulmuş
olduğu için ne yatıyor uyuyor zaten
ve okulun ne kadar oyun dostu yaparsak
yapalım şunu farkettik Eğer benim
öğretmenim dersinde oyun oynamıyorsa
okulun oyunun dostu olmasında hiçbir
anlamı yok o yüzden dersinde oyun
oynayan öğretmenlere çok ihtiyacım var
dersinde kutu oyunlarından da yararlanan
ve mümkün olduğunca dersine oyunlar
katan öğretmene çok ihtiyacım var
Okulu oyun dostu okul yaptık öğretmeni
oyun dostu öğretmen yaptık gene yetmedi
Aslında en önemli paydaşlardan biri olan
oyun dostu ebeveynlere ihtiyacımız oldu
ortaya çıktı bizim çocuğuyla oyun
oynayan anne babalara ihtiyacımız var
şimdi burada ebeveyn
lere soruyor
onların çocuklarına gidiyorum soruyorum
karşımda 500 600 tane çocuk var kimler
diyorum annesi ile babasıyla oyun
oynuyor diyorum 3 kişiye saldırıyor
sonra birinden biri yalan söylüyor yani
ya
ama çocuk aslında şunu söylemeye
çalışıyor yetmiyor diyor yani yetmiyor
Evet yetmiyor O çocuklar oyun oynama
Çünkü biz sokakta o ihtiyacımızı
giderebilirken şimdi Çocuklar evde o
ihtiyaçlarını Evet maalesef
gideremiyorlar O yüzden anne babaların
çocuklarıyla oyun oynamalarına çok
ihtiyacımız var
Aslında Neye ihtiyacınız var biliyor
musunuz biraz
elektriklerin kesilmesine ihtiyacımız
var
Eskiden elektrikler çok kesiliyor
hatırlıyorsunuz değil mi elektrikler
kesildiğinde ne yapıyordunuz diye
söylüyorum ne yapıyordunuz elektrikler
kesilince
oynuyorduk sohbet ediyoruz şu an herkes
gülümsüyor ne gülüyorsunuz hocam diyor
Çok güzeldi ya çok güzel ya madem bu
kadar güzeldi buraya işlemiş şuraya
işlemiş ya ve çok da güzel hatırlıyorsun
madem bu kadar güzel hatırlıyorsun Neden
bunu çoğaltmıyorsun böyle deyince de
Ebeveynler diyor ki Ne yapalım hocam
şalterleri mi kapatalım onu mu
istiyorsunuz diyor ya o da değil mesele
Mesele Aslında beraber güzel vakit
geçirmek kaliteli vakit geçirme birlikte
etkinlik yapsam birlikte Aslında
birbirimizin gözünün içine bakmak
onların hepsi işte buraya işliyor Neden
peki neden bu kadar çok buna
ihtiyacınıza neden oyun oynama
ihtiyacımız var mazlumun ihtiyaçlar
hiyeraresini bilenler vardır belki Evet
hep mutlu olmak için yapıyoruz ama
bazılarına ihtiyaçlar hikayesinde bize
diyor ki işte Temel ihtiyaçlarımız var
diyor Onun dışında emniyet ihtiyacı onun
üstüne ait olması sevgiye ihtiyacı
başkalarına saygı görme kendine
saygılarıma en tepede kendini
gerçekleştirme ihtiyacımız var
en tepede güçe Yıldız koymuşum
farkındaysanız neden olabilir sizce
üçünü oyunlarla karşılayabiliyorum
[Müzik]
Lütfen annemi de ben yiyorum babamın da
ben kaybedemem diyor Ağlıyor çocuk kim
yeni gerçekleştirememiş biri
kendini gerçekleştirmiş bireyin diyor
oyun oynadık diyor güzel diyor
keyifliydi diyor
Bir dahakine de biz kazanırız diyor
takım olduğu zaman arkadaşlık kurduğu
zaman işte o aslında kazandığı zaman
başkalarından saygı gördüğünü de
hissediyor Ben kazandım diyor bak diyor
onları ben yendim diyor biz yendik diyor
ağlayan çocuk ne oluyor mesela ağlıyor
ağlıyor ağlıyor ağlıyor Ondan sonra
ertesi gün veliyi kapat
a hocam
dün siz oyun oynamışsınız
Ee bizim çocuk kaybetmiş
Ee Hocam biz çocuğa hiç kaybettirmiyoruz
Biz hep kazandırıyoruz
Siz niye bartu'yu kaybettiriyorsunuz
çocukluğun ağla ağla ne yapacağımızı
bilemedik ya hemen psikologdan randevu
aldık
ya Biz çocukla yakalanmaç oynuyoruz bir
çocuğu yakalamıyoruz
Saklambaç oyunu Biz bulamıyoruz Biz
çocuğu yani o derece Biz çocuğa Hiç
kaybettirmiyoruz ya Veli de farkında
değil ebeveyn O yüzden oyun dostu
ebeveynine çok ihtiyacım var yani çocuğu
kaybettiğinde Aslında daha çok şey
kazandığını anlayabilecek ebeveyne de
çok ihtiyacım var ki ebeveynleri de
burada çok iyi anlıyorum çünkü onlar da
aslında bu işin bir eğitimini almadılar
bizim anne babalarımızla almadık ama
bizi Anne babalarımız bize Anne babalık
yapmadılar Bense çok net söyleyeyim bize
saldılar sokağa
tık dedi sokakta akşam ezanı olunca gel
dediler Biz orada Sosyalist arkadaşı
bütün her şeyi sohbeti Hallettik Evren
hazır bir şekilde geldik
şimdi bütün o şeylerle uğraşan biziz
Yani biz uğraşıyoruz şimdi bir
çocukların bütün o şeyleriyle Evet asıl
anne babası şu an şimdi kendine babalar
yapıyor
şimdi mazot ihtiyaçları yerleştirip
pandemi de özellikle güncellemek zorunda
kaldım ben artık en temelde farklı
ihtiyaçlarımız ortaya çıktı ama
bakıyoruz mesela kedilere köpeklere
hayvanlara bakıyoruz bunları oyun
oynuyorlar mı diye sürekli oyun
oynuyorlar Hatta biz de atasözü var
oynamayan Tay at Olmaz diye O yüzden ben
diyorum ki sevgili öğretmenlerim
eğitimcilerim ebeveynleri unutmayın
Mazlum'dan önce gelir diyorum Mazda Az
önce anlattım
ihtiyaçlar Hiyerarşi bunu Bloom ne diyor
bloom'da Diyor ki kardeşim diyor benim
diyor ulaştırmam gereken hedefler var
diyor işte bilgi kavrama uygulama analiz
sentezleyelim en tepeye kadar
çıkartacaksın diyor Ben ne diyorum
Mazlum yani çocukların ihtiyaçları her
zaman daha önceliklidir sizin kazandığı
kazandıracağınız o kazanımlarda
yeterince oyun oynuyor mu çocuklar diye
işte okul öncesi En çok oyun oynadığımız
yer belki Türkiye'deki en iyi çalışan
sistemlerden bir tanesi okul öncesi çok
güzel oyunlar oynuyoruz
bir başlıyor
müfredattı bilmem neydi falan filan
çocuk oyun oynuyorum bakın nerede hiç
oyun yok Dikkat edin
nerede sınav var orada oyun yok Onlar
dokunulmazlar zaten biz onlarla
araştırmada yapamıyoruz sekizler 12'den
kimse dokunamıyor
bak Gidin yükün tez arama motoruna girin
hiç tez bulamazsınız onlarla ilgili
hocam Dokunmayın onlara da
Çünkü onlar 8-12 bunun bunları kimse
kimse bir şey hani güzel bir oyun
oynamak Hani keyifliydi onlarla oyun
oynayalım diyoruz öğretmenimize Diyoruz
ki oyun çok önemli Oyun oynayın derste
Öğretmen gidiyor dersinde oyun
oynattırıyor Ertesi gün okula basıyor
hocam Bartu eve geliyor Çok eğlenmiş
yani
biz bu çocuğu bu okula oyun oynasın diye
mi gönderirsek oyun oynatıyormuşsunuz
lütfen ya biraz daha test çözmeniz lazım
değil mi ya bu çocuğun test çözmesi
lazım test Çünkü sınava girecek bu çocuk
bir araştırma yaptık
onunla ilgili bir de araştırma yaptık Bu
arada Ama bakın nerede sınav var orada
oyun yok hani çok ihtiyaç duyuyorduk
hani çok güzeldi hani çok keyifliydi en
çok ihtiyaç duyduğumuz anda
en az yaptığımız şey oyun oynamak oluyor
bir anda
Hani güzeldi
oyun dostu okul projesinde koridorlara
geziyoruz öğrencilerle sohbet ediyoruz 8
sınıf öğrencisi yalvarıyor hocam diyor
ya
geçen sene Okula gelmek için bir gün en
azından bir nedenimiz vardı
neydi Siz yine de
beden eğitimi dersimiz vardı Şimdi artık
8 olduğumuz için onu da kaldırdılar
artık okula gelmek için bir nedenimiz
kalmadı ne olur En azından şu Beden
eğitim dersini geri getirin diye bana
yalvarıyorlar
Dolayısıyla test test test test test
çözdürelim Tamam bir araştırma yaptık
bir gruba hafta sonu kursta sürekli test
çözdürdük
bu grup böyle sürekli test çözüp durdu
öbür gruba da hafta sonu kurs da oyun
oynattık ama dersle ilgili oyun oynattık
bunları her ikisine de konu ile ilgili
test yaptık Ondan sonra bir grup test
çözdü bir grup oyun oynadı en sonunda
aynı testi tekrar yaptık
bu kadar anlat
tığımıza göre herhalde test çözeceğim
En kötü ihtimalle şimdi şu önce şunu
söyleyeyim yüzde seksen oyun oynayan
Grup daha başarılı çıkıyor cepte mi
cepte Peki %20 araştırmalar bize ne
diyor yani çıkan en kötü Sonuç ne
diyelim ki 20 soruluk bir test veriyoruz
biz bunları en başta 20'de 2-3 doğru
yapıyor bunlar atıyorlar çıkıyor falan
en sonda
test çözen Grup 20 soruda 15 doğru yaptı
ortaya çıkıyor iyi mi
Hayır fena değil değil mi
oyun oynayan gruba bakıyoruz çıkan en
kötü sonuç 20 soruda
bunların da 15 doğru yaptı ortaya
çıkıyor
ne demek şimdi bu
he
bir gün böyle sordum uyutan Öğretmen
dedi ki hocam ne kasıyoruz ya o zaman
dedi
dedim ki Hocam bunu Akademik olarak
yazamıyoruz ama hani bak neden bu kadar
çok bu çocukları zorluyoruz Yani neden
bu
kadar Dolayısıyla ben şunu söylüyorum
Aslında öğretmenleri ya bir dakika daha
fazla oyun oynarsanız Bu çocuklara çok
iyi gelecek amaç bütün ders oyun oynamak
da değil bir dakika bile daha fazla oyun
oynarsanız bu çocuklar daha başarılı
olacaklar Aslında ve biz bunu
kaçırıyoruz bir şeyi kaçırıyoruz yani o
yüzden oyun dostu okullara Evet çok
ihtiyacınız var peki başka Duygulardan
dolayı hangi duyguları hissediyoruz oyun
oynarken
duygu var oyun oynarken hissettiğimiz
bir kahvede giriyoruz
duygular ben oturdum duygularla ilgili
araştırmaya başladım İşin içinden
çıkamadım
hangi duyguları hissed acaba oyun
oynarken diye Sonra oturdum hangi
duygular var zaten diye baktım ve onları
indirdim
bunu da size bize birçok duyguyu da arka
arkaya hissettiren bir şeyden
bahsettiriyor bahsediyorum ve maalesef
son zamanlarda çocuklarımızın yeterince
duyguyu hissedemedikleri özellikle
Rehber öğretmenler bana hep şunu
söylüyor Hocam ne hissettiğini bilmiyor
ne hissettiğini bilmediği için içeride
bir sıkıntı yaşıyor Bunu ifade edemiyor
ifade edemeyince de evet yani şu an ne
hissediyorum Ben diyor
ve oyun oynadığımız zaman biliyorsunuz
mutlu oluyoruz seroton hormonu
salgılanıyor ve yeterince bunu
hissetmeyen çocuklarda maalesef
depresyona giriyor
O yüzden oyun oynamaya çok ihtiyacım var
sadece duygular içinde değil tabii ki
beceriler için hangi beceriler gelişiyor
diye bakıyoruz
hayal gücü becerilerimizi gelişiyor
yaratıcılık problem çözme Strateji
Geliştirme kutunun dışında düşünmeye bak
şimdi oraya girmiyor oraya da girmiyor
Ulan diyor ben bunu buraya nasıl
sokacağım diyor
farklı düşünüyor yani bunu oyun oynarken
yapabiliyorsun dijital oyunlar oynarken
de yine birçok beceri gelişiyor eldeki
kaynakları en iyi şekilde kullanmaya
çalışmaz strate Biz bunu becerilerin
hepsine ne diyoruz 20 birinci
birçok okul ne diyor Hocam diyor Bir 21
Yüzyıl beceren geliştiriyorsun sizi
bilmiyorum ama biz 21
sonra bakıyorum biz bu becerilere sahip
miyiz diye
takım çalışması liderlik yaratıcılık
falan
yok şükür diyorum yani hani çok da fena
değiliz gibi geliyor bana sonra Diyorum
ki bu Yere göğe sığdıramadığımız 21
yüzyıl becerilerini 20 yüzyılın
çocukları olan Bizler biz bunları
sokakta elde ettik ya
Dolayısıyla cevabı çok uzaklarda aramaya
gerek yok aslında cevap yine burada
oyunlarda
Ve tabii ki bir de kaybetmeye
başladığımız bazı değerler var değil mi
Son zamanlarda özellikle fark ettiğimiz
sevgiyi saygı adalet hoşgörü gibi
ve bu değerleri de kaybetmeye
başladığımız zaman bakanlık ne dedi ama
biz bunları kaybediyoruz Ne yapalım dedi
O zaman biz bunu ders koyalım değerler
eğitimi ders verelim çocuklara değerleri
kazanırlar dedi
yine ne yaptık Daha fazla ders yaptık
çocukların oyun süresinden daha fazla
aldık
Halbuki neye ihtiyacımız vardı Daha
fazla oyun oynama ihtiyacımız vardı
işte Umarım bu projeyle oyun dostu okul
projesiyle oyunlara daha çok değer
verdiğimiz çocuklara daha çok
oynadığımız hem öğretmen olarak hem
ebeveyn olarak okullarda çocukların daha
fazla oyun oynadığı bir noktaya erişiriz
Çok teşekkür ediyorum dinlediğiniz için